dans la famille castaldi je demande l'un
des fils simon le deuxième enfant de
benjamin castaldi fait aujourd'hui
parler de lui dans la presse puisqu'il a
décidé de se lancer lui aussi dans la
télé réalité en face et en mer celtique
et benjamin castaldi
si son père a été l'animateur de love
story de sica story c'est du côté des
candidats que son fils de 20 ans va
aujourd'hui faire son entrée dans
l'émission de w9 les princes et les
princesses de l'amour et gérard décision
pas forcément simple qu'il a prise en
famille mais alors comment son entourage
et surtout comment son père benjamin at
il réagi si vous laissez votre enfant
faire pareil
ils ont été en direct avec nous ce soir
pour nous parler de cette aventure alors
c'est bon et avec nous regardez moi ces
beaux gosses j'adore j'adore cette
qualité de cheveux c'est la qualité dieu
arrête tes magnifiques thébaux mon chéri
été arrêté botté très bon tu sais que
ton père c'est comme mon frère et je ne
rigole pas 16 ans je l'aimé énormément
et vraiment c'est mon frère n'a pas
recruté dit il est petit mais alors oui
mais et je laime il le sait c'est mon
frère d'amour ici qui pourra toujours
compter sur moi à part si pour le moment
déjà demandé comment ça va vous sinon
très bien merci
alors tu va intégrer les princes et les
princesses de l'amour alors donc toi tu
es célibataire peut pas répondre non
mais avant d'entrer ttc par rentrer donc
on est célibataire on cherche l'amour
d'accord si rares jeunes voilà ou
pluvieux d'accord d'âge et le but c'est
de trouver la prétendante qui va nous
correspondent le mieux taf un casting
g on m'a appelé j'ai fait une vidéo
casting savait qu'ils étaient tous deux
majeurs à kastali sont dit ça va peser
wahou sur moi bien sûr sur entier a bien
sûr il a 8 ans ils l'ont appelé pour
qu'il fasse les princes et les
princesses l'amour donc je suis dit non
j'ai un peu joué
le nom a joué dans le nord a joué bien
jouer y compris direct alors faut
comprendre un truc c'est que sur les
princes et les princes et les
prétendants d'accord pour être prince
faut d abord un stade fiu ou voilà faut
être déjà un peu dans le milieu moi j'ai
quoi des biscuits lu attendant moi je
suis prince à des princes au dieu
bénisse
ça va être dur tu nous casses les
couilles est clos des princes je vois
donc je suis prince c'est ça qui a joué
donc avec mon nom j'ai pu être prince
jean raymond n'ont jamais leur histoire
était un peu différent de quand sobriété
valais voilà est-ce qu'ils sont les
princes les principes sont fois de plus
que les autres les principes son prince
du coup c'est ça courtisé par lens il
sait comme le bachelor mec plein de
prince exactement c'est fort c'est est
donc prêt à s'associer
alors donc vous étiez content d'être
pris pour un casting j'ai été content
j'étais pourquoi vous voulez faire quoi
dans la vie mois de beta en sport
business et passeport tout le monde les
bacs plus de sport c'est sport business
for business alors donc non j'avais
crise naissent passe par la business
jboss pour le business c'est un business
qui fait du business dans le square même
temps c'est sûr tu pas masqué maintenant
c'est clair c'est quoi ça vient toujours
te fous agence de cluses
voilà maintenant il ya plein de choses
ya agent de joueurs marketing sportif et
y parle
d'accord d'accord
et donc voilà et donc voilà et donc la
table sur qui non non c'est pas comme ça
d'accord excuse moi comme il
ouais donc au vide traite non essentiels
comme plein de jeunes comme moi qui
était en cours qui je pense ont dû
chaviré dans un truc qui était
compliquée parce que quand on est jeune
on a 20 ans a bien sûr moi je n'ai pas
un grand fan des cons j'ai mon bal tout
ça j'ai eu la base c'est ce qui m'a bien
forcés c'est utile si la soirée mais
voilà si je veux dire les chiens ne font
pas des chats c'est vrai oui
et donc quand je voulais être dans sport
business en business ça me plaisait bien
profiter donc malgré tout annuler et ça
c'est fini j'ai annulé parce que on m'a
appelé on pas toi tu fais des princes
[Rires]
pendant le confinement sur instagram des
live once de l'amour un peu live mais un
peu pour voir comment ça allait prendre
part à certains moi parce que j'avais un
peu peur par rapport aux noms et tout
finalement ça de marché d'accord j'ai
pris pas mal sur les réseaux et de là
j'ai été appelé par surproduction
d'accord dont les princes dont les
princes voilà donc c'est super comme ça
et donc ça y est tu vas faire lé prince
tu veux faire une carrière dans la télé
on verra je peux pas les faire quoi
c'est quoi ton rêve franchement je sais
moi j'ai envie de vivre j'en ai 2 qui
fait mal envie de vivre voilà j'ai envie
je sais pas vraiment ce que ce soit dans
cette envie de vivre
je sais quoi ton rêve
mon rêve c'est être heureux dans ma vie
faire plaisir ma famille quoi vrai je
sais pas quoi faire vraiment précisément
je peux suivre les traces de son passé
compliqué car c'est un très grand animal
ton père et la partie du top 10
franchement nicolas on est d'accord
baccarat aujourd'hui dans les émetteurs
de jeu il y en a deux ou trois mètres
dans l'histoire la qualité partis du oui
même de ça c'est que je pensais comme
les joueurs de foot est ou pas quand ils
ont un papa qui ont été très forts je
pense à zidane tout ça son fils est très
bon oui mais bon
ouais on dira toujours c'est le fils de
zidane et il sera jamais à son niveau
c'est dur et la droite site appelle papa
s'appelle toi six mois nous là dessus
sa part est en jeu non mais n'arrêtent
pas simon maintiennent toi toi tu veux
qui fait je me suis fait pousser peser
les brasses de l'amour ou par cpi à la
haye donc c'est bien payé aux pages soit
pas ça parce que j'ai pas de foot dans
la calle c'est soit tu l'as dit at on
passe à la paix alors j'étais l'homme
que chez lui pendant confinement ça
j'étais chez lui pendant qu'au final à
un accord donc j'ai eu l'appel je vous
dis papa et tout donc on a parlé
beaucoup on a parlé de trois semaines
des écoutes
au début c'est compliqué t'es sûr il
était passé au début
non il était quand même dans le doute
non j'étais en fait la vérité c'est que
sage de contexte à fait quand on le
connaît on sait que dans le sport ça va
être compliqué aussi pour c'est vrai que
trouver des stages maintenant on savait
que ce soit dans le management ou qu'on
savait que ça va être compliqué pendant
deux trois voire quatre ans et m'a dit
écoute pourquoi ne pas tenter cette
expérience j écoute l'a annoncé je l'ait
prévenu je vois là ça va être compliqué
tout appel castaldi juillet surtout sert
à rien de faire genre je me plais pas
castaldi qui les dépasse 9 7 à castaldi
voilà c'est comme ça et c'est pas une
honte dans tous les métiers on est on
peut aider ou moins bien sûr à prendre
avec cypher vous avez peur pour lui ou
pas non j'ai pas parce qu'il a il a
d'abord il m'a vu vivre donc il a quand
même vu les bons et les mauvais moments
et sont parfois les mauvais moments de
ce qu'on peut avoir comme comme d'aude
avec les réseaux etc il est franchement
il est déjà assez armé et puis on il est
encadré il est à la maison là où il
s'installe et tout ça parce que c'est un
grand garçon mais honnêtement j'avais
pas de parler avec ça et c'est pas la
première fois plus que des niches
fiscales a été appelé parce que figurez
vous que vous avez failli avoir dont
s'arrêter norma ceci dit dans ces
catégories
il avait appelé julien avec son second
aurait été mon père a été le pionnier
des terralies dès qu'il fait scrat est
assez marrant julia n'a pas voulu y
aller parce que m'ont aidé m
mais bon c'est bon ils avaient ils
avaient rendez vous vous étiez dans
secret story mon père était le pionner
des vachettes
j'aurais bien mauvaises grâces de
dirhams ont tu ces écoutes atterit et
c'est de la merde et moi je continue à
penser que c'est un tremplin et que dont
fera jamais d'un âne un cheval de course
mais si la ligue du potentiel voilà
c'est une manif à son double de cire
connaître j'ai pas trop avec ça après
c'est à lui de jouer
s'il est bon ou pas j'étais pas venu
dans les prince mais sinon dans ce qu'il
fait dans ces vidéos et où il a du
talent j'attends qu'il a du talent ce
qu'il était d'abord il est très beau il
est il est rapide et il a un physique
qui est un peu qu'un qui pas comme ce
n'était le mec de télé réalité ils sont
bons mais il a un physique un peu
différent évidemment photo il n' y
passent très bien donc il a peut-être
plein de chose qui peut découvrir après
voilà pour le sol avec les ipad 2 ipad
mais il n'a pas volé j'attends une
carrière ceux qui disent non pourquoi
vous dites non pas que vous auriez pas
laisser votre fils dit toi benjamin et à
simon nicolas pernikoff alors lui serra
sera tort c'est quoi lui tu lui même
j'ai gagné au loto cent cinquante mille
50 millions je sais pas comment tu vas
faire couler c'est une galère que la
famille sur le dos tu vas te demander de
lozère je préfère être dans mon cas rien
à voir non mais tout dépend de la
motivation vous savez bien qu'il ya des
milliers de jeunes qui rêvent de gagner
de l'argent est investi relaté un hit et
me permet d de l'argent qui se
retrouvent dans les embrouilles pas
possible bon là on est mal barrés simon
je le connaisse un garçon déterminé il
veut faire du business il sait où il va
je ne peux pas faire carrière avec la
téléréalité donc c'est différent mais
c'est vrai que personnellement non je
souhaiterais pas que mon enfant demain
pourquoi phase d'atterrissage dépend de
l'objectif
simon l'a expliqué il a expliqué qu'il y
avait une opportunité qui avait fait
qu'il fallait de la télé réalité
maintenant moi je connais un peu simon
s'il n'y avait pas eu une copine si sa
vie avaient été normales et du sport et
business quoi c'est sur l'église et
réussir à ce niveau là donc tu vas
réussir en sport et business bien sûr
ils ont été dirigés alors bon c'est bon
tu entends ce qu'il dit est ce que vous
vous le connaissez voilà pourquoi vous
auriez dit non ils réellement inhibant
exactement pour les mêmes raisons qui ne
fonctionnaient plus c'était il ya deux
heures seulement reste un peu car ils
bloquaient guillaume cpdm risque
d'enfermement le l'argent l'argent un
peu un peu facile à la dérive à la wii
voilà j'ai peur que on se résorber mais
que l'image qu'on donne soit mal
interprétée par d'autres est content
ferme là dedans
maintenant cela dit annie parmi d'autres
propositions c'était quoi les autres
j'ai eu la ville a aussi qui m'a la
villa et vous avez le coeur brisé
bah non parce qu'il faut avoir le coeur
brisé pour aller voter les gens rigolent
ils serviraient vous voulez vous on
appelait donc à loïs et la villa des
cobras is et je n'ai pas y aller non
c'est pas comme ça parce que c'est réglé
en gros il se base sur des
problématiques d'accord que j'aurais pu
avoir
donc ça aurait pu être un peu vous
auriez préféré taire la villa des coeurs
brisés ou là le prince et princesse
marche mieux les points oui les
principes et la villa au cci les
marseillais bah je pense que les mercis
et maintenant il faut plus d'autre part
s'il faut être quand même en lien avec
des citoyens oui ça veut dire si tu as
un pote que tu as connu qui était pas
qu'ils passaient route c'est bon mec
comme moi ce fut super copine qui était
d'accord très bien aux cartons non moi
je veux pas trop taper sur la témérité
parce que c'est des cibles faciles mais
c'est un peu de la poudre aux yeux comme
ce monde on sait pas trop s'il ya de
l'argent si on n'a pas les belles
voitures d'où ça vient
c'est la notorité facile c'est l'argent
facile et c'est les influenceurs enfin
c'est la ville influence ouais mais
moins chaud que pour un jeune
aujourd'hui qui fait un travail normal
qui est vendeur
boulanger aux policiers comme on avait
l'autre jour qui gagne 1500 2000 2500
euros c'est dur ou de voir que des gens
qui sont influenceurs et qui en
apparence sauf pour certains qui en ont
fait un vrai métier mais font pas
grand-chose pardon mais c'est pas d un
travail qui est dur labeur non mais
c'est vrai laissez-le répond non mais je
juste j'ai une question sur la presse
parce que tous les candidats aujourd'hui
120 en 25 ans je sais pas comment on
peut faire carrière là dedans il ya 45
ans d'avoir dit la vérité dans a bien
sûr c'est pas bien sûr isabelle ils ont
demandé de l'attendre
la villa des coeurs brisés aussi bien
mais c'est vrai alors oui je pense qu'on
peut monter plein de business à côté
maintenant il ya le e-commerce qui est
beaucoup et qui est très à l'aise en
donc on peut te faire plein de choses il
ya des agents qui se passe si on est
bien entouré sur la voix lasse on est un
bon groupe de personnes avec qui on peut
faire des affaires ça marche et
dites-moi si mauvaise que ça toujours
été facile d'être le fils est vrai d'une
grande vedette par germain c'est vrai
qu'il est très très très connu benjamin
c'est un des animateurs les plus connus
est ce que ç'a toujours été facile parce
que c'est avec moi je me pose souvent la
question vaut mon fils et est petit mais
c'est vrai que quand on grandit comme ça
ce que c'est compliqué avec des périodes
compliquées quand comment à 12-13 ans
qu'ont les gens commencent à comprendre
un peu le show biz tout ça il ya un peu
de tout il ya des jaloux des gens
intéressés et il ya des gens sincères
moi j'ai des copains j'ai très peu de
potes moins de vrais amis ouais j'en ai
depuis battu déconner un ep je suis tout
petit et c'est ma base après j'ai eu des
moments difficiles
ouais ouais surtout il ya 4 5 ans quand
c'est un peu plus compliqué pour lui qui
a dû partir et où je pars faire l'avion
pas pleurer mais ça a été compliqué
parce que je les jeux les très peu vu
moi j'étais en pension à cette époque
33e donc ai eu beaucoup de choses qui se
sont emballés et au final ça a été dur
mais bon j'ai manqué de rien et j'ai eu
ma mère très présente aussi gérard vous
avez été très présent c'est ici que
j'étais le moins présent rattraper le
temps perdu mais sinon c'est vrai que
c'est celui qui m'avait été le moins
parce que je suis parti il était tout
petit donc on a rattrapé le temps perdu
mais ça ça qu'est bon et on est ensemble
depuis maintenant il depuis qu'il a 14
ans 15 ans donc on rattrape au tandoori
moi j'ai pas de preuve avec ça même si
c'est vrai que si mon jeu on le sait
c'était ça a été plus compliqué pour lui
mais on sait c'est scélérat bonaly mais
c'est ce qui fait aussi qu'il est comme
il est qu il a son caractère et qu'il
est fort et qu'il est et qu'il est plein
d'ambition et que ça c'est un bon gars
c'est un bon gars je suis pas inquiet
pour lui vous allez soutenir évidemment
les zones non mais j'étais jeune j'ai
toujours soutenu tous mes enfants
évidemment julien dans son travail aussi
travaillé que my albert l'a d'ailleurs
donc moi ils sont ici ils sont là dedans
c'est un univers qui leur plaît monsieur
julien et voulait il a il a essayé à la
télé en tant qu'animateur s'il n'a pas
plu puis il est passé à autre chose avec
aucun problème il n'y ont pas ils n'ont
pas d'égaux par rapport à un rapport au
métier d'animateur et si on lui propose
d'être animateur qu'il est bon c'est
bien apprécié les psys n'est pas bon ça
comme pour tout le monde parce que le
piston c'est bon pour moi les prendre
pour en finir c'est le piston c'est
ennuyeux quand vous prenez la place de
quelqu'un parce que vous êtes moins bon
mais si vous êtes bon voilà c'est comme
celui qui prend une charcuterie de son
père s'il fait du bon boulot c'est pas
grave si c'est de la merde c'est plus
emmerdant c'est important de faire du
bon boulot mais certaines boucheries du
fait du mauvais boulot c'est bon c'est
pas manqué d ou alors j'étais sûr que
vous alliez à dire oui vous dit non non
moi je dis non parce que j'ai toujours
entendu benjamin se plaindre et et c'est
tout à son honneur et benjamin sont très
potes c'est kelly qui connaissait
benjamin elles connaissent et qui vous
dit non mais benjamin et moi c'est
vraiment ça leur rend frère dans le sait
vraiment mon grand frère mais justement
ce que je suis étonné de son choix et de
son discours alors bien sûr on soutient
toujours son enfant moi j'aimerais
rester mais je suppose qu'on le soutient
mais après le fait qu'ils disent
bah oui mais non enfin moi benjamin je
l' ai toujours entendu triste de ce qui
arrive que ce soit pour lui ou pour ses
enfants quand 30 les enfants s'en
prennent plein la tronche
il est triste pour eux quand lui s'en
prend plein la tronche ses enfants son
triste pour lui donc moi je me dis un
moment donné peut-être qu'il va vouloir
que ça s'arrête et que ses enfants ne
prennent pas la relève justement de ce
truc là bas faut maintenant maintenant
je prends qui honnêtement les mois je me
suis très jay vraiment éloigné de dd
raison du cas de twitter avec rihanna
mais il ya du très bon il ya du moins
bon il ya du dégueulasse parfois mon
attente j'ai pris beaucoup de recul
il m'a vu faire
je pense qu'il a beaucoup de recul et
puis il c'est une chance énorme c'est
vrai que par rapport à d'autres
candidats il m'a mis là il a vu ce
métier il a vu ce qui était de musc
était bien ce qui était moins bien il a
vu les pour le problème des réseaux
comment on pouvait se faire agresser
d'une a reçu des menaces de mort au
moment où la salle ap ap savannah plus
déranger moi que l'huile à celui lui
c'est son univers il est né avec les
réseaux il a il est un téléphone dans la
main depuis qu'il a 13 ou 14 ans donc je
pense qu'il est largement armée et kiki
là et qu'il aura aucun problème s'est
mariée aux amériques deviennent
animateurs ont pas mais je pense qu'il
agit pour être honnête bon il va m'en
vouloir je pense que simon n'ait pas
fait pour l'animation
ah ouais voilà je pense à sa façon la
rue non non non pas du tout façon
juliette est plus fait pour ça je pense
que moi c'est votre ccc plus tôt enzo
qui peuplent le spleen unis la mairie
fans de musique vous allez vous lui
donnerez vous donneriez des conseils est
ce que vous avez un regret par un jardin
de roses car il ya un truc que vous
auriez vous avez fait que vous n'auriez
pas dû faire dans les aimions que j'ai
pu me présenter
ouais même dans votre carrière voilà au
même âge et moi j'ai eu vent gg non j'ai
fait une haie j'ai fait des erreurs de
posture au début on en a parlé hier
oui mais dans les illusions que j'ai
fait honnêtement j'ai eu la chance de
faire des émissions incroyable j'ai été
pionner dans plein de domaines j'ai
dansé sur le tard j'ai fait le loft sur
tf1 j'ai fait un jeu de la doré qui
était un contre sens j'ai eu des beaux
succès après j'ai fait là le concert en
live de johnny donc j'ai pas de regret
je pense que j'ai connu tout ce qui
avait de beau dans ce métier après
peut-être que peut-être que là où la
fortune à 11 heures du matin sur tf1
peut-être que j'aurais pas dû faire ce
que pour le coup et c'est vous qui
présentait la roue de la fortune
voilà donc
c'est vrai tu information soit bonsoir
et bienvenue dans la roue des muffins
nicolas pernikoff et là j'ai la rage et
j'ai beaucoup de chance dans mon métier
et je suis encore très heureux de cette
belle carrière
vous qui êtes animatrice aussi est ce
que vous auriez dit oui vous pouvez vous
rejetez vous avertissent par un petit
mot de la marine à paris voilà il a 20
ans et votre messi est bien l'auteur que
benjamin je le suivrai quoi lui dans la
vie lui le travail dans les relations
internationales
en accord l'appel relations
internationales star quand on dit ça
c'est quand on veut non mais ouais tu
parle anglais
la diplomatie non les choses comme la
voix si j'adore comme joe boyd et que
j'écoute simon est effectivement je
comprends que ton père ta compagne et
parce qu'évidemment de te patronne
accompagne ses enfants quoi qu'il décide
et puis c'est leur vie on va pas vivre
par procuration leurs panneaux revit
mais en revanche je trouve presque
dommage parce que je tuais brillant tué
portiques et est intelligent mais déposé
corti qui est oui mais voilà je suis
décortiquer et j'ai peur pour toi que
justement tu sois ensuite enfermé avec
une étiquette qui est celui de moi je
prends deux candidats de télé réalité
est que tout ce qui aurait pu s'offrir à
toi en garde jeudi le site internet
valérie ce sera toujours su le fils de
ben wallace alias sérieux oui c'est ce
que j'essaie de démontrer enfin voilà
fait que je montre qu'il était vraiment
moi en tant que simmons et voilà moi
j'ai fait les princes pour ça même si je
serai toujours le fils de benjamin gps a
envie de montrer qu'il dit qui je n'ai
plus envie d'être
vous avez envie d'être un cast a dit
vous avez surtout envie d'être je suis
un castaldi et j'en suis très fier oui
j'aimerais qu'on dise ah c'est simon est
pas le fils d'omar jamais d'accord c'est
ce que j'aime ascal qui voulait juste
oui parce que moi je voudrais de revenir
sur le sujet c'est que lui moi par
contre si la question est est ce que le
fils de benjamin castaldi peuvent faire
latéralité j'aurais dit oui parce qu'il
est encadré il connaît le métier
benjamin ma mémoire je dis non à
quelqu'un qui ne connaît pas ce milieu
d'accord voilà ça c'est une première
chose
ensuite il faut pas mélanger tout c'est
à dire ne pas faire de la télé réalité
c'est pas parce que ça donne une sale
image ou que tu es un débile c'est ça ça
parce que l'or parce que les gens maria
ça c'est pas vrai moi j'en connais
beaucoup c'est des gens hyper
interrogerait les entrepreneurs donc ces
deux choses maintenant lui
protéger une grosse moi ce que juste que
césar didot c'est que là il est nouveau
ça arrive
il ad il a des bases il a un père qui
est derrière qui lui ne fait pas ça moi
ce que je lui demande tu le vis comme un
tremplin c'est que comme un ghetto
moment donné tu vas être dans la la
tourmente dans ce tourbillon
c'est de rester toujours accrocha
tempère pas toujours parce que moi j'en
connais beaucoup ils partent qu'ils
soient dubaï ou loin des parents les
parents leur écrire et pour ne même plus
ouais maman j'ai pas le temps reste
désolé il en arrive à mais plus répondre
à leurs parents parce que ça y est 100
dans le tourbillon les potes c'est
amical
voilà moi j'en connais beaucoup on a
parlé avec des gens que j'aime beaucoup
de la télé du rapport avec le père la
mère qu'ils en oublient pas qui les aime
plus mais ils sont dans la tourmente ils
sont légion et là au début c'est nouveau
ils ont tous des principes
voilà sinon je vais pas faire si la lui
il à son père qu'il protège pas bernard
montiel we kiss him réveillez vous
l'avez non non mais moi qui suis moi
même animateur voulait pas rappeler si
gentil celle plus vous non ce que j'aime
bien c'est qu'il a la tête sur les
épaules mais le pire dans ce métier pour
ça moi j'aurais préféré que nom du
groupe
c'est que c'est la célébrité je crois
que c'est très difficile de quand on
devient très célèbre parce que vous
allez être célèbre la suite de ça en
plus d'être le fils de benji et la
célébrité il ya plein de pièges à éviter
moi j'ai tout vu moi c'est le procès
s'agit là tout connu gênant tout connu
mais j'ai vu les choses mais dans le
vide qu'il fanni retrouve à louvain voir
les images non je parle des réseaux
sociaux en fait après les candidats
c'est très dur pour eux il suffit vous
n'avez pas peur simon un pâtre avère si
jamais il ya un candidat qui trompe
l'autre par exemple ils ont une énorme
communauté et ils se font insulter ces
démissions d'élus liés au cul le fossé
sans les téléspectateurs ce qui est ok
bon bah ouais c'est vrai oui 26 mars en
nombre à 74%
bah ouais d'accord enfin s'ils sont
d'accord avec isabelle avec le sud il
s'en fait un petit peu pareil qu'ici et
benjamins voilà ici moi je vous souhaite
que ça se passe très bien on simon et
sitel moins de soucis bien sûr tu
appelles ton père et ton père
je peux te dire ton papa séné comme ça
c'est une bombe ne l'a jamais mais
vraiment jamais